welcome to this video for around seven
of the bill tournament and yet today we
saw three games um which had two draws
two drawers they were played them
between onigiri and hikaru nakamura have
a pretty uneventful game I think um
which pretty much was even for tho whole
time at least uh with a quick look I
would say it was rather even all the way
and another draw between a TN back row
and Victor Borge on who managed to get
on the scoreboard after losing his first
four games so we had got those two
drawers and the third game which is also
the game i'm going to show now it's
between one how from china the brilliant
leader of the tournament at the moment
he's got four wins i think and one loss
so great score against Magnus cards and
was on plus 2 e 12 games and drew the
rest he won yesterday the postponed game
against oregon after a tough battle and
today accountant playing black IAM
trying to yeah i think trying to win in
order to catch up here with one now so
let's see what happens we have one now
playing a deform he's some playing also
he fought he mixes it but i think 44
game where safety is not a bad thing i
think he opts for deform at magness
plays the Queen's Indian so not very
sharp opening from the outset it's not
like I know he's going for the
blumenfeld or Ben Oni or something to
try to win but rather try to play a long
game and wait for chances later so oops
this wasn't intended one how playing g3
now the yeah maybe the main movement
zishan and cards and playing Bishop a
six on attacking the sea for porn and
white needs to attend to this threat of
course I'm one how place p 3 now the
thing main move there are lots of
alternatives for a while Quincy to was
some the fashionable move but b3 is the
tried-and-tested mainline black now
drops back to be seven and you could ask
okay what's the big point of this white
has an extra move with the move be three
levels to but v3 is not a move that it's
always useful for white it can also be a
weakening of the Queen side we can see
them in the count of line that Magnus
plays some what what one point of this
might be so Bishop g2 now try and Bishop
b4 check Bishop d to this is actually
the only move if white would try the
somewhat unnatural move here then yeah
this is a bit unpleasant to say the
least but it's a neat little trick this
is also one explanation of this b3 move
if v3 wouldn't have been I wouldn't be
played then Ned Beatty to for instance
could could have been played and because
gypsy three is not possible of course so
we should be too and now Carson plays c5
covering the the bishop on reform this
line he played a couple of times before
and one idea is to ya to get possibly um
complicated queenside structure if white
would take on before I didn't do that
but he could it's a normal move why it
could take you and black recaptures and
yeah now the ideas that this be for porn
is yeah maybe slightly loose black needs
to attend to the
spawn but it also restricts the white
knight on v1 so this night cannot go to
his normal square on c3 and play might
continue like this year let's say
castles both side and then maybe a three
to get rid of the porn and actually
allow and proper development and this is
a rather normal way to continue and this
position is maybe around equal problem
maybe it's very slight advantage for
white but nothing special this whole
line is pretty okay for blankets nothing
nothing big to worry about but one who
played differently he just canceled here
and Carlton as well and now Bishop c3
now my day six and here one he'll play a
move which slightly surprised me played
a three it's not bad of course it's am
perfectly playable I just thought that
the idea of all this this setup with
bishops III was to play Bishop b2 here
to sort of us like okay what is your
bishop doing and this pretty much
provokes them the following something
like this and this leads to a pretty
standard head shock kind of position for
black which should be a around equal
maybe a very slightly better for white
but it's a pretty typical hitch head
shock where the bishops on on g7 and on
b7 and g2 I exchanged and this usually
helps or black a lot because the Queen
gets a nice square on b7 and it's not
not much to to worry about again it's
this is aronian against cards and
actually from 2011 I looked at up
because I remembered that Magnus played
this before so this is an alternative
for white but he decided to not play we
should be too but to play em to play
this a 3 move so exchange here and this
have course the difference and the other
setup black actually could retreat the
Bishop to e7 here the dark squared
bishop sigh exchange so this square for
instance the size it is an issue now and
black government decides to go for the
mentioned headshot kind of setup and 95
so it's the net shock but both bishops I
exchanged Luke see one these are all
pretty am normal looking moose I think
and now I decided to to kick the night
the whole structure here with a3 and b3
looks a bit a bit weekend so it's pretty
much mandatory that widened some point
place be form and allow some gear for
instance this night and the Queen to
move that b3 is not weakness anymore so
I push us back the night and of course p
7 is not a great great square for night
so it continues pretty much as you would
expect that 95 pushes the Queen back and
co ND through d3 completing a
development getting the rope to the
default and black plays a useful move
giving some moved here for the king so
it's kind of faced in the game where
you're just trying to find a good setup
yeah black am of course recognize that
be 7s a bit weird so we attack c4 and
reroute the night to e8 can not be one
who wants to protect c4
tens nie to to d2 and night back to e8
and 92 the other night only ages are
actually not so bad that has got various
ideas maybe at some point 97 or even 96
if possible it's not not such a bad bad
square ok so queen bee seven now pretty
normal connecting the rooks yeah and in
this position we get them first critical
moment growl how played c5 now it didn't
need to do that it could have played a
normal move and pretty much keep the
position it's a very difficult to to do
something yeah very straightforward he
could have played a move lucky for of
course and then black yeah I think
pretty much employs a sit and wait
strategy it's not like blackheads you
chum ideas for activity but ok I think
the main idea and this position for for
black if you try to win this position is
too yeah to just drag the game on until
the time ticks down and then try
something with let's less time on the
clock um ok he went for c5 so for pretty
much concrete approach yeah I'd hear
it's quite interesting here Magnus took
on c5 he also had the opportunity to
play something else he could have played
85 and I think um this just pretty much
equalizes the game without much troubles
I think he just didn't want to do this
at this point to keep some some chances
for a fight um I think this is just just
very equal Y term doesn't have much
better than playing a normal move like
you form and then something like this
should be should be around equal maybe
as a it's hard to tell but actually if
you would really am want me to choose
one side I actually would choose black
here because black has the better King
in this position but it should be around
equal it's not much not much happening
move like night be 3r ooh k 1 stuff like
that it's it should be equal so a 5 was
the the move to play if you just want to
keep it down in the drawing range but
you didn't want to do that he took on c5
white recaptures a queen a 7 yeah in
this position 1 how also had an
alternative he played Ned to to be three
another possibility was to to put the
the denied on the square which isn't
isn't a bad idea the idea is that this
night might go here and this night here
and I think the some offers some chance
is to to try it for an advantage for
example 95 night c4 okay to be 8e 497
and then let's say that be six maybe and
here white should be better really I
think this night for to be three was was
slightly better but they decided to play
the other move not not bad yeah I'm not
bad it so it's easy to to tell
afterwards but why should be I think
look slightly better now anyway not not
a big big advantage but not playing a
five well it was slightly risky
like now 195 and here why played the
very straightforward move c6 which
obviously was a yeah I guess the idea of
playing this night to to be 3 and here
magnets played d take c 5s and this
continues the policy of playing moves
that keep the fight going because he had
the alternative to take with the rook
actually and i don't think he overlooked
the possibility i think you just didn't
want to do that the idea is that if
white takes with night now black has got
this this is naudi check on e3 and this
is some quite ok 44 black if white plays
something like this you can play a 99
txt one and you've got this opportunity
here so what this should be a rather
equal let's say quindi one takes here
and well just grab c6 for example and
this should be equal it's helpful for
black to yet have exchanged some
material him to release some some
pressure but he didn't do that he took
with the pawn and this sir is yeah
really somewhat somewhat risky here one
how played a form he had a good
alternative really in 95 it's hard to
tell if it's really better but it's a
good it's a good alternative I think
your black needs to play 97 I move like
c5 is very risky after after this the
black wing gets into some trouble now
and for example Quinn b6 they've got
this efore move coming and if the night
moves then you have no g7 check just
winning and black gets into real trouble
here so you cannot you cannot play this
c5 move you have to
to play this pretty modest 97 and then
it just just goes along these lines and
yeah now probably moved like doing here
and why does probably slightly better
with the knight on c6 but black shirt
should hold it was an alternative for
white what he did was yeah more
ambitious he played a form 97 and now 95
yeah black has some has an extra pawn to
c6 one but of course yeah it's not a
phone with with you chure with the huge
future at the moment because it's very
safely blocked why does got those great
nights and attacks all those weaknesses
so white obviously has a very good
compensation for the porn and it's very
hard to believe that yep like actually
can get out of this with some sort of
winning chances because you're so tied
down to the weeks to week pawns but
let's see what happens he played down
Knight f6 first of all activating this
died only eight and right now drop this
bag probably intending this move and
also clearing the way on the default for
the Queen ER for the rook at some point
so 96 black pretty much cannot do much
he needs to sit and wait what is trying
to do is reroute this Knight to d7
possibly to challenge one night here on
on c5 so Quincy three intending this
night back to f8 as described and our
Knight a5 look a to be eight this rocker
on an open file make sense and a wide
plate a for an alternative them and
you could also consider route d6
directly attacking the c6 pawn may be
here and then a lengthening move here to
cover the second-ranked so that this
move is not possible and it's very hard
to suggest something for black ears so
tied down to its weaknesses and white
has got all these active pieces I think
it's some it's a bit difficult to
analyze this position the only thing
which is pretty much clear to me that
that this shouldn't be worse for white
at all the only question is is a wide
actually better maybe but it's not easy
for me now to to analyze this without
getting to a one hour long video I think
why has very good chances but it's hard
to tell exactly how to make progress all
right so we played played another way
but this is very similar in played a for
this King h8 yeah just sit and wait I
guess and now rock d 6 bedroom p 1 but
now route is six what's the very decent
alternative and i think this is really
the more the better move ma'am because
um it's simply that rugby one I think
just helps black because I'm exchanging
one pair of rooks is helpful for black
you really want to keep the material on
because black has got less space and
yeah the rule of thumb says if the
opponent is some space does it want it
you should keep the pieces on it's not
so as usual in chess it pretty much
depends on the concrete position I think
this is one of those where you shouldn't
exchange I think this may be sports a
bit of of the advantage rugby 6 yeah
maybe white could just return now yeah
well he took yeah but maybe you can if
you want just return and let's say
what what should like do to improve its
position we can just sit and wait
alright but he took this was the
intention and now night to be seven with
the idea of possibly getting the night
to d6 would show it's not not a bad idea
of course Group B 896 one thing to pay
attention to us the clocks Magnus alarm
on 20-something minutes and one house
down to six minutes and I think he
really got some problems with the time
coming so 96 and black went back to g8
so this King edge it wasn't the greatest
idea ever maybe but simply no not much
to do now route d2 and black played a
five moving away this this pawn here
from a possible attack on the ape on the
a porn 93 m possibly intending this also
this move to get on a five-night to to
d7 and we're pretty much nearing the
critical phase of the game here we're
getting close to time control 94-96
queen essex and now here's a critical
position here one how I'm could have
made I think a pretty straightforward
draw with just taking on a five which
you didn't do it's not necessary to do
this but I think this um just would draw
instantly let's have a look at this if
you would take blacks ideas and I think
to play c5 and I think maybe he didn't
like this this kind of position I'm just
speculating here this kind of position
where black threatens our main in one
which is of course a pretty pretty
uncomfortable white can meet this with
rook f2 maybe he just saw this kind of
variation you decided okay don't want
this because white still has
compensation for the porn
but I think 95 was a very
straightforward draw maybe he was also
still thinking of playing for advantage
is possible I mean if white gets the a
pawn unpunished and keeps its own a pawn
then he's got an passport on the 8th
also white can try but this was a very
safe choice now considering the
tournament standings and maybe this was
the way to go okay when he played rukka
c2 which is not not bad I mean that's
not a bad move I'm black now c5 moving
is on C porn and now played rugby too
yeah you can say why not rugby to
immediately about Roxy to was a move 40
so probably am he just needed to make a
safe move and thought afterwards I'm in
this position here and mine was played
rugby sevens pretty much passes and here
there was an alternative maybe not the
one for fourth fourth category what is
it twenty super tournament and i moved
to consider here with rook before i just
want to show the idea because it's not
so silly as it looks at first you think
okay my just blunder london exchange but
this is actually a pretty well aditya
the ideas of what takes now you take
with the a porn then in this position
you have straightened your pawns we've
got down to connected passed pawns here
and one possibility might be to to get
the night to deform i'm funny enough the
computer gives black full compensation
here um yeah to be honest I don't really
believe it that it should be for
compensation but okay I don't want to go
into an hour-long analysis again but
this is an interesting idea i think i
will an idea you should keep in mind
that sometimes when your porn up it's
very interesting to consider exchange
sacrifices that improve your pawn
structure and give you passed pawns this
kind of IDM route before for example
would be a thing much stronger both
sides would would have
one extra rukon so that black baby can
create more threats for instance if you
had rook on the default okay it's a
possible idea but it's also very risky
so you in Carlin's position here of
course he wants to win but if he loses
in the game volvo tournament is just
just just over then why would probably
just win the tournament and he he cannot
for the loss the end with rugby seven he
just keeps the position and so much
going on here white exchanged here and
in this position he again could play it
very safe was just just taking him and
it's a it's quite Josh I think let go
see end always has some counter play on
the a porn it's a very likely to end in
a draw here one thing is if you look at
this you need to keep in mind these kind
of things and it can that can get get
very tricky for four wide okay yeah
black headless least has some perpetual
here okay so 95 again the safe movie
played queen bee too though which is
still fine the ideas some if black would
exchange now which you didn't then this
would leave wide with yeah nice
advantage which you can probably press
home to win with very good technical
play white will get the a porn so
something like this year and then you've
got the a porn yeah white has I think
pretty decent winning chances here maybe
black should hold but it's very
uncomfortable to to play this very
uncomfortable okay so black of course
didn't exchange he played Queen a six
and I want home plate will be five which
looks a bit weird at first sight
offering the exchange of Queens with the
porn down but this is still perfectly OK
and black does
have much choice he needs to take now
and push the a pond yeah and now we're
nearing the yeah the kind of crunch time
of this game it's a it's an endgame wear
white at this point really needs to to
hear pay attention to this a pawn what
actually only has one move here and he
didn't play it he needs to play be six
now and this would i would simply draw
the game we can look at the following a
three which is the only move the only
player will move if black would play
something like this here then you've got
the problem with with with b7 coming and
white threatens 95 now dislodging this
night from the bh square so stuff like
this i mean and yeah what should like
doing it soon go back here and then why
just wins the spawn and returns a very
good winning chances i think he is
winning actually so I'm black after b6
needs to be alert he needs to play a
three so the only move everything else
leads to a close loss position and then
you've got very simple 93 96 95 and
check-ins just just dead this position
yeah but in this in this position here
where b6 drew um one now played the move
Knight d2 b 2 and in this position them
I would advise you to maybe stop the
video and look and look for yourself
what black should should do in this
position I'll be silent for about 10
seconds now so if you look for a good
move for black eye
right back now hip like plate the very
strong move Knight b6 and congratulation
if you if you spotted this the and the
very nice idea is if white take this now
then a three and the a porn promotes
it's a very cute take very cute idea the
DEA porn is just unstoppable now and
what you really need to to keep in mind
is this kind of configuration with the
pollen on the sixth-ranked the of course
i mean the the the the rain fell apart
the a on th pond if you got to this
position and checking this night on on
be too in this instance or it could be
g7 g2 just this candle fianchetto would
no idea and detected with a six-armed or
similar depending on the concrete
position then this pawn just promotes
its not stopped below so very very nice
optically and the fun thing is that
those night also cannot this night also
cannot help it just promotes so i'm a
very nice motive so this was the nice
trickier hope you spotted it I think one
how may be so I to I'm not not quite
sure because this is a very common motif
here this a threesome is a three thing
um again the problem is some now black
him yeah got his night activated this d7
night and he actually manages to
exchange one pair of nights which he
could only dream about a minute before
so after this the position really shifts
from pretty comfortable draw to a very
problematic for white if not maybe it's
already a.m. yeah I'm not not savable
anymore it's hard to tell but obviously
black is now better you can you can see
this now because now both Black Knights
are working and he has no chance to get
his pawn back
King III and black activates the skin as
well and our f5 stopping everything in
its tracks so that wider doesn't get
more space advantage here in the center
you know took unknown on their five and
played them Kingda three guinea 7 and 9
a-3 um Knight f6 and night see form
exchanging one pair of lights yeah night
c4 he could if he could have considered
of course also taking with a king but
like this in time to to cover the pawn
and he will go on 95 of next month so it
doesn't help very much he had took took
with the night and here knight to e form
I think in this position white could
have defended slightly better but it's
just a very brief analysis that I could
do here he played down this move 95 the
alternative I think would have been too
well maybe player play King c2 probably
intending this year getting to the a
pond and just the possible line here
let's say 922 G 6v6 it's a very tricky
you always have to watch for those pawn
moves with nights because nights are so
bad at stopping pawns the sir also
promotes so b6 kingly seven King needs
to help to to stop this pawn and now the
funny move 95 which she also the King
from the pond and I think maybe this is
a tougher defense and some I couldn't
really invested so much time to try to
figure out if this is winning Black has
those chances chances of course but it
can easily drift into something which
you which you actually cannot win um
for instance something like this if you
just that just push the pawns let's say
c4 here oh no need to go here first King
see aid and maybe stuff like this year
just just a sample line it's not fast in
any way night be three nights e-form
yeah this trick again for the sea porn
yeah just just the position like this
here and here watches very decent
drawing chances he should should
actually draw this with the pawns on
just one side I mean you can you can
fight I think this was somewhat tougher
defense yet this this King see to move
but I think one was also ya think pretty
shocked by now that he actually got
himself into this trouble and it was
mostly yeah him getting getting into
trouble he could have drawn so many
times with pretty pretty straightforward
moves but somehow didn't do it picking
the eighth another King approaches
quickly this pawn g4 yeah maybe not the
best but i think it was not not savable
anymore I'm yep here cars and just just
took it it's pretty much yeah in your
face move because white cannot capture
again the a porn just push it through so
I'm yeah white needed to recapture and
then 96 and note this great night
position takes away this critical
squares for for the white king and the
pawn and the night control the whole
fourth rank so it's a very nice ammonia
set up very very aesthetic so ya know b6
and now the King just approaches the
pond
and yep and it's over something like
this year and then like get the spawn so
uh yeah but when a win for cards and in
this very critical encounter for the
tournament victory in Beale so it's now
tied to tighter with one how both our
players got 13 points they've got this
three point system and it's really
uncanny our often cards and wins those
critical games out of positions where
you think okay it's just a draw what
what is what is this how should you
possibly win this but somehow he manages
to do this so often it's not a matter of
luck it's really a matter of yeah still
um yeah playing in a way that there's
some life left in the position and
giving the opponent really some chances
to go wrong um okay here to see is a
pretty pretty pretty hard example where
this move really gave the game away
overlooking this trick but um yeah I
took some chances some risks here like
to trying to win this game and God
rewarded in the end I think it could
have easily gone wrong if one how ya
played slightly differently in the
middle game but it was difficult wasn't
easy to find so I think all in all ready
deserved wynia for black all right um so
this tournament yeah gets pretty gets
pretty close now at the top so there was
leading but geary and nakamura are not
far behind so celebra things possible
yeah thanks for watching and i think
i'll do some more beer videos for the
next couple of rounds of their
interesting games so watch out for this
thanks